MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section, we're
going to further investigate
the energy momentum for
vector, which we introduced
in the previous sections.
But here, we focus on the zeroth
component, the first component
of this vector, where
we find mass in A
for particle A times
the proper velocity
of the zeroth component is equal
to mA times c times 1 over 1
minus uA square
over c square, which
is the energy of this
particle A over c.
Or in other words, the energy
is equal to the mass times c
square over 1 square root of
1 minus uA square c square.
So let's discuss or look
at-- let's have a look
at this a little bit more.
The first question we can ask--
how does this now look like
for particles which travel
with reasonably low velocity?
So uA-- much smaller than c.
So we can Taylor expand
this following this equation
here, which we
discussed earlier.
And we find that the energy
is equal to mA c square.
That's the first
term, which we call
rest mass, the energy given--
just the rest mass by the
mass of the particle times c
square, plus 1/2 mA c square
times uA square over c square.
The c squares cancel.
And we find what we know as the
kinetic energy, 1/2 m v square,
or in this case,
1/2 mA uA square.
That looks very familiar.
So the energy of a particle
is given by its rest
mass plus its kinetic energy.
All right, now investigating
this for vector,
then we can ask, how does the
invariant interval look like?
How does this property,
which is invariant,
and the Lorentz transformation
look like when we multiply
the vector with itself?
Here, we find minus E square
over c square plus the 3
momentum squared is equal
to minus m0 c square.
Or in other words, we find this
energy momentum, energy mass
relation, energy
momentum mass relation,
where the energy is given by
the momentum square times c
square plus the rest mass
square times c to the 4th power.
Again, we can unroll this
now and ask, how does this
look for a particle at rest?
And again, we find the
energy is equal to mc square.
No surprise.
That's how we started
the definition of this.
In general, we can
find that the energy
is equal to a
relativistic mass times c
square, which is equal to the
rest mass times gamma times c
square.
And that's equal to the rest
mass times c square plus k,
the kinetic energy, square.
All right, does
this definition--
I can tell you that this
confused me as a student
quite a bit.
This understanding that
the mass becomes heavier
for a part of this-- really,
one I didn't quite like.
I just like to think about the
fact that the kinetic energy--
there's a relativistic component
to the kinetic energy, which
is owned by the
particle in addition
to the rest mass of this
particle times c square.
Also interesting to note is
that for particles at rest--
particles which are
massless, like a photon,
the energy is equal to
the momentum times c.
If you want to know what
the energy is of a photon,
you need to know
what the momentum is
of the photon multiplied by c.